hello there today we're looking at fnet
mixing tokens with fourier transforms by
james lee
thorpe joshua ainsley ilya eckstein
and santiago antonion of google research
i know i'm a bit late with this one but
it's sort of a not only this paper but
it's a really interesting
direction that's happening right now in
machine learning in general in deep
learning in sequence models
in image models and so on and that is
the sort of giving up of attention
mechanisms
so for the longest time we've been
focusing on
transformers and in a transformer
you technically you have some sort of a
sequence as an input
and then you push that through these
attention
layers the layers are actually always
made up
of attention sub layers and then feed
forward
layers so every layer would have an
attention sub layer and a feed forward
sub layer or multiple ones of them
now the feed forward sub layers they
would be
sort of acting individually on the
elements
so the weights are shared there is one
feet forward layer
and the tokens every token goes through
that
feed forward layer so this can be
efficiently parallelized or shorted or
you can
make things like mixture of experts
where tokens go to different
ones there's a lot of stuff possible
however
here in the attention part this was
always a bit of a
thorn in the eye of most people
because while the attention mechanism is
definitely a
cool mechanism it needs a lot
of memory and compute in fact the
attention mechanism needs to decide
which information in this layer's
uh sequence goes to which information
in the next layer sequence so where does
the information go into the next
thing from this token and then from this
token does it go here or here
who knows the tension mechanism's job is
to figure out
what information goes where it's a it's
a routing problem
and as such it has a complexity
of o of n squared is if n is your
sequence
length and also it has memory
requirements of n squared
and that prohibits it from scaling to
larger sequence lengths so we would
always be sort of
limited in the length of the sequences
in which we could input
or which we could input which prevented
it for example from being applied to
computer vision for a long time
until people figured out actually we
don't need to
put pixel by pixel here we can just sort
of subdivide
our image into patches and do that and
then we can use
the transformers but still this
limitation of the sequence length
is a result from the attention mechanism
having
this complexity uh right here
and people have been chipping away at
that complexity
for a while now so we've had a a
about one or two years now of constant
invention of linearizing
this attention mechanism so to get that
from
o of n squared to sum o
of n or maybe n log n
or something like this or something
manageable maybe a constant
maybe n times k anything but
n squared so we had lint former and long
former and reformer and synthesizer and
uh i don't even know if synthesizers in
the same area but
performer and
um linear transformer
there are so many uh
what what would be called linear or or
non-quadratic attention
mechanisms trying to approximate
basically this attention routing problem
now we've entered into a new era now
people are questioning
do we even need the attention layer
at all and i think the or
one of this this comes all comes at very
very similar times right now
so even after this paper there there has
been
like at least three papers since then um
trying to actually just actively get rid
of the attention
layer in the sequence models which is
super
super interesting so
we're going to have a look at how do you
get rid of the attention layer that
has apparently given sequence models
such a boost and what do you replace it
with and in this particular paper the
answer is very much
fourier transforms now we're going to
get into
why fourier transforms but essentially
they present
a model that looks like
this so it looks very much if you've
seen my video on on attention or
anything
since then this should look very very
familiar
to you namely there is an input down
here
then uh the input is split
into words sequences of words or word
pieces
maybe and then each of these word pieces
gets a word embedding so this is a table
where you look it up
it gets a position embedding and maybe
gets a type
embedding so if you want the most direct
reference maybe go
watch the video on on bert
right okay so the
the next step then is n
times this layer right here and
this is where usually the attention
would be
so but instead of the attention
this would be here now you have this
what's called
the fourier uh layer or whatever
we're going to look at is in quite a bit
the output is
a dense layer and an output projection
and then an output
prediction so as you can see this is
very much
like a transformer except it says
fourier
instead of attention so
just so you're aware of what's going on
this is the
this is the thing they change they they
don't change
any other thing except this sub
part and what is this subpart this
subpart
is characterized in this formula right
here
but essentially what you do is you have
your
input to the layer right so x x would be
whatever goes into
the layer right here and then of course
this would be like x0 and then x1
would be go back in n times
all right so x what is done
this is a fourier transform so you apply
a fourier transform to x now you might
ask
how can you do that x is not a
uh a like a continuous signal like a
sound wave or something like this
remember that the way we view sequences
here is as a series of vectors so
every input element at the bottom will
get
mapped to some sort of a vector uh
as many vectors as you have tokens
and as many dimensions that's that's
something
you decide by yourself so
you you're going to have a bunch of
vectors right here
and you do a fourier transform first
over the well let's see first over the
hidden domain
and then over the sequence domain so you
do a fourier transform
over this domain and then you do a four
a one so a one d fourier transform over
over this domain
right um each individually and then a
one d
fourier transform in each dimension but
across
the time domain right here
and that's it there is no parameters
involved in this thing
this is simply a fourier domain in the
time domain and the fourier domain in
the hidden dimension domain and that's
all
and the only learned parameter in this
whole
setup are i guess the normalization
might have
some fine parameters but these feed
forward parameters are then the only
learned parameters okay this is
quite a departure now
if you if you are a bit confused
let me go a bit more into this fourier
transform
you might first of all see right here
that we are only interested at the end
in the real part
of the output of the fourier domain
what does the fourier transform do the
fourier transform
what it usually does is it takes some
some sort of a signal
and it transforms that in
a reversible linear fashion
into a let's say a superposition
of um of these basis
functions so these basis functions in in
the case of fourier transform they're
uh these how do you call them
in english these these uh like sine and
cosine waves of different frequencies
right
very much what you're might be used to
from the position encoding so
the fourier transform would give you
that the top signal is like
three times this plus five times this
plus nine times the the bottom one
okay so the this signal right here
would be transformed into this signal
right here and you can do an inverse
fourier transform
as well the formula for the fourier
transform
is is pretty simple this is it
you decide how many components you want
you can represent any signal
exactly if you have infinite components
uh but you know as we deal with real
numbers we just cut off somewhere
and then you have the fourier transform
and the inverse transform
is simply uh if you don't do the
negative sign
right here so you can in fact do this by
simply constructing this matrix here
ahead of time and then multiplying by
this matrix and there you really see
this is just a linear transformation of
your data okay and you you do it once
column wise and once row wise uh to your
signal
and there you have it that that's your
that's your your layer no learned
parameters at all
now why might this work
um and the
the second part of the paper right here
that
we are have we we didn't really look at
yet is what they call
mixing tokens and they make an
emphasis on this and i think i think
it's really smart so this paper
isn't about the fourier transform it is
not
advocating that the fourier transform as
such
is in any way special rather i think
what they advocate for is that the
mixing of
tokens is special so the mixing
of information between the tokens now
what do we mean
so if you have a sequence any sort of
sequence and you want to do computation
with that sequence if you want to
understand the whole sequence at
some point information needs to flow
between
the elements of the sequence right
now if you look at an image for example
it is it's quite natural to
or let's let's go a different way
how does a convolutional neural network
flow information
well a convolutional neural network sort
of restricts information flow to a
neighborhood
so what it would do is it would let
information flow in this neighborhood
and let's do non-overlapping
kernels maybe in this neighborhood and
then this neighborhood
and then in the next layer right now
there's only three elements
in the next layer it would sort of let
information flow in this neighborhood
and also
let's include that twice in this
neighborhood now there's two elements
and then it would let information flow
like in this neighborhood
and then you this node right here has
sort of a global overview over the
whole sequence whereas this node here
only had an overview over a local
subsequence
we accept this and for images it makes a
lot of sense
this is exactly our prior for images
is that what's first and foremost
relevant to like a pixel here
is probably the surrounding pixels and
then the
objects if the image contains objects
they're probably
sort of in the neighborhood-ish of
of that broader area and so on and then
on the highest level we want to com you
know the relationship of objects
to each other we want to understand that
so that seems like a natural prior to
have
however in text it's a little bit
different
right um in text it might very well be
that here at the end if anyone has ever
tried to learn german that here at the
end is a word
that just kind of references in
like intrinsically as a first layer of
information
the second word in the sentence or
something like this uh
like a verb helper verb construction
this this is very common in language so
there is not
at all this locality of
of of information given and therefore
routing information fast between
elements of the sequence is very
important
uh especially when it comes to language
but it also
is important in images because as we've
seen the vision transformers they also
work
quite well um so routing information
between stuff is
is very uh very helpful in
in language and this locality might not
be as helpful might actually be damaging
if you only get to learn about your
distant uh
distant away tokens you know three four
or five layers down
that just limits your ability to do
computation
now the attention mechanism is exactly
right
what facilitated these connections
between elements of the
different uh across the whole sequence
right because
it an analyzed every single possible
connection between two things
and then it decided okay these are you
know the important connections
what this paper is saying and i guess
other papers that have come out
since like the mlp mixer and and the
uh pay attention to mlps and and also
this
is you know it might
be it might not be so important to
decide
exactly how information should flow
between
far away elements it might just be
enough
for most tasks if information flows
at all right if if we just somehow
get information from one side to all the
other or from one token to all the other
tokens
then um then we
we uh we facilitate this transfer
of information and that might be enough
the exact
routing might not be as important as the
fact
that information is flowing and that's
what the fourier transform ultimately
does
right here because if
you um if you transform
your time domain right this is
step one step two step three step four
if you transform this
then a little bit of of
of the one token is is
in is influencing this number a little
bit is influencing this number a little
bit is influencing this number
and for two three and four as well so
the
time domain is completely destroyed
right
but the the frequency domain is split up
and then in the next step when you do a
fourier transform again
you do very much the reverse you sort of
go back into the
time domain even though i'm i'm not
convinced that
applying this twice like in the next
layer again will
bring you back is that is that the exact
reverse
i don't know someone someone with uh
more knowledge of this should probably
evaluate
if i normalize correctly is applying
this
twice and taking the real part after
each one
equivalent to performing the fourier
transform and then it's inverse
i'm i'm not sure what i'm sure of is
that um this this
the fourier transform will absolutely
stack
the time domain on top of one another
while splitting up the frequency domain
and if you apply it again it will do the
the opposite it will
stack all the frequencies on top of one
another and split up the time domain
the signal is the same but the feet
forward layer
are applied differently remember the
feet forward layer is applied
individually right to so there's one
feet forward layer
one box and it's individually applied to
each of the elements of the sequence
so the same transformation now
what happens if you do the fourier
transform and then
apply the feed forward to each element
well
now the elements each element is no
longer
corresponding to a token but each
element is corresponding to
one frequency across
all the tokens in the entire sequence so
now
the alternatingly the feed forward the
feed forward layers can work
on the individual tokens or on the
individual frequencies across all tokens
right and i think ah this is the same
this is a bit like you remember we i
don't even remember what it was but we
had
we had a tension so if you look at an
attention
matrix axial attention that was it right
where you
if you like if these are like two pixels
uh the attention matrix between all the
pixels would be too
expensive but you calculate sort of the
attention
in the columns and the and the rows
and then it takes two layers because
first
uh that pixel can attend to this one and
then in the next layer
that pixel can attend to this one it's a
bit like this
right where um
you get anywhere like you can route
information from anything to anything
in two steps instead of one
the reason so that that's what the
fourier transformation does now you
might ask
why the fourier transformation and to be
honest
and i think that's also the opinion of
this paper
right here uh and i think they say this
in the conclusion i'm gonna i'm just
gonna skip a bunch of stuff
right here they
i think they say they've looked at other
transformations so
we found the fourier transform to be a
particularly effective mixing mechanism
in part two the highly efficient fft
that's the fast fourier transform
it is quite remarkable that an
unparameterized mixing mechanism can
yield a relatively
very accurate model on a practical note
we only perform the cursory survey of
other linear transformations therefore
we believe there may be value in
exploring
other fast transformations so
the fourier transform was chosen because
it was readily available in libraries
but it is it is just a mixing technique
and i'm even i'm even open to the idea
that
to fourier transform is like the optimal
mixing technique
here of all the linear mixing techniques
you could come up with
but what seems to be important is just
the fact that you do
somehow get information um around
between the tokens
and that you operate sometimes on the
individual tokens and you
operate sometimes across the tokens with
your transformations
and for a lot of tasks it might not be
that crucial
exactly how that information is routed
right
so i think that's the the sort of
takeaway
message uh from here now with
with respect to experiments um
it is not better than transformers so
just say this from we've we've quit the
era of i want
like here's a new state of the art and
we've gone into the era of
it works almost as well but it is faster
and also
in a very particular plot with very
particular axes it is better
you're going to see that not that it is
bad right but
essentially what they claim is look
we have something that's way faster
you're going to sacrifice a bunch of
accuracy
for that and depending on your task that
might be
worth it or not worth it so
here's the stuff they compare birth base
which is uh the transformer model they
compare with
the f net which is we replace every self
a tension sub layer with a fourier sub
layer
as described in section three two that's
what we just looked at
then a linear encoder this is
interesting
right let's actually first let's go like
there's a random encoder
we replace each self attention sublater
with two constant random matrices
one applied to the hidden dimension one
applied to the sequence dimension so
this is just like a constant scrambling
um this is this is
like the fourier transform except it's
less structured like it's just kind of a
random
thing and that's why i say the fourier
transform might be the most effective
non-parametric
mixing method here because it kind of
makes sense and i do think it
outperforms this random encoder
quite a bit um and then there's the feed
forward only that only
does feed forward that doesn't do any
mixing at all
um yeah there is no token mixing as you
can see here
the linear encoder we replace each
self attention sub layer with two
with a two learnable dense linear sub
layers
one applied to the hidden dimension and
one applied to the sequence dimension
this i mean this is the this is the mlp
mixer
now i get it mlp mixer was specifically
for vision
and you know people might have tried
this before not saying they invented
this particular thing they might have i
don't know but this
is exactly like it's it's funny that
this appears again right here
in fact when you look at the results
this linear encoder
performs quite well
um it of course has more parameters
right because
this one has no parameters instead of
attention
whilst the linear encoder actually does
have
parameters it's just not as compute and
memory intensive
as attention um so what works well is
this linear encoder works quite well
which gives you know gives credit to mlp
mixer as well
and also what works well is what they
claim
later a hybrid version so when they use
the f net but at the
end they like in the last few layers
they actually use attention
so again this is it's not better
it's a trade-off and the trade-off is
speed
and longer context size
for accuracy
so if yeah here you have the here you
have the
number of parameters
and there you go with the first losses
so this is pre-training
loss right so pre-training loss in
uh in masked language modeling
and next sentence prediction and also uh
accuracy on the right hand side you see
bert
is bert is just winning here uh the
other ones
aren't like not even close
right i guess a bit close so you can
also see
that the linear here outperforms the
f net interestingly the f net
outperforms
random way so it's not like
it's not like any mixing is fine right
yeah that's
the interesting part here because the
random one
is whatever like just mixed information
um so that that is interesting to see
and that
gives hope that we might come up with
even better
transformations than the fourier
transformation
um yeah we
i guess didn't the synthesizer also try
to
learn the attention matrix at that point
i said that doesn't make sense but
maybe you know we find some sort of
universal
or what not attention matrix that is
just better
i have no idea i'm just talking crap now
and then you can see that the hybrid
here also performs fairly
well uh but this is just pre-training
for now if you then okay the speed up is
i mean speed up is of course a lot
um there's a you know decent speed up on
tpu
and a massive speed up on gpus
so you know that's that's where these
models shine they're very fast
um in terms of evaluating these things
this is the glue
benchmark it's a bit you know i think
it's debated of how useful
these benchmarks really are but it's at
least a number
you can measure and you can see that
bert
is very much winning in most of them
though there are some
where it is not like okay i
like i don't even know what these what
these tasks are but i
they the authors here say especially for
example in the bert
large case um the this is quite unstable
so this is fine tuning by the way they
pre-train on the
uh on the big corpus and then they
fine-tune right here
this can be unstable for example for
example look here like the bird
large is actually worse than the bird
base in this one which i guess is
only due to training training
instability
but they did say they they tried a bunch
of times
i guess i i guess it's also a factor if
a model is unstable right if you really
want to go into production
with it that's an issue so you might opt
for something more
stable so you can see that in most of
these things
bert wins there are some times where
something else wins like f net or f net
hybrid though keep in mind these
these benchmarks um sometimes
they are they are rather just
like a benchmark like a number uh
in overall bert wins
by quite a bit though it is followed
by the the hybrid model and
then the linear model and the f net
model aren't
too far behind um
also if yeah if you look at the large
one though i think
the large one is simply kind of bad
because it's unstable
so this might be more of a training
instability issue
than the fact that this model is somehow
um exceptionally good
yeah it's it's it's it's quite
interesting because i also compare these
numbers to
to jacob devlin's original paper and
they were
quite different uh the glue numbers
and so i'm i'm a little bit
wary about just these numbers and just
sort of
thinking of know how much variance do
they actually have
between different implementations
between different runs and so on
and that sort of um
makes me a bit cautious with these uh
things
they do as i said so here
they plot masked language model accuracy
versus time per training steps for
64 examples in the log scale and
in one region of this plot
they are uh the ethnic and linear net
are
better which is i i hope you agree with
me it's a rather
specific plot to plot and
even in the conclusions they say
something like you know for a given
time and for a given time
and accuracy budget here
we demonstrated that for a fixed speed
and accuracy budget
small ethnic models outperform
transformer models
which is okay there's like a measure
where you have
where you're better which is cool right
but
at the same time i think the the message
is really that here's a trade-off that
you can do
lastly they evaluate on the long-range
arena
so the long-range arena is sort of a
textual task
where it's somehow important that
you remember things for a long time or
that you can address
uh sequence elements over large
distances there's like
list ops these are not necessarily
natural language tasks but more like
constructed tasks with the explicit goal
of testing the long range capabilities
of these models
and of course
the transformers see still seem to be
best but of course the question here is
very often if you have long sequences
you can't use a transformer
and therefore you have these other
models that you can see are not too far
behind
but they do use considerably less
memory and compute
and they don't yeah they don't run into
fail
as often they train way faster
so i'm also a bit skeptical of this long
range arena
results because it sort of it sort of
seems like as
as soon as you can remember whatever it
is you need to remember
you you sort of solve the tasks um
so there's not there's not like it
it's more a bit of a binary thing you
either get there
or you don't rather than there being
um rather than there being some sort of
nuance to it right now uh we might
get once i guess once we get more robust
models that work on longer sequences
that might change
in any case yeah it's cool to see that
you know
you see in the average numbers these
models
are not too far behind the transformers
and they train way faster as i said
okay so that was it
um for this particular paper
as i said this is it is a paper about
fourier transform instead of attention
but it's much more a paper
about the importance of
mixing information
between tokens that is an important
concept
and the available trade-offs that
there are tasks there are situations
where
you don't need the attention mechanism
you don't need this full
power this full analysis and
in those cases it might be enough to
just somehow
mix the information the fourier
transform being one attractive option
because it doesn't have parameters and
it has very very fast
implementations and it sort of makes
sense on a conceptual level
so that was it from me do
check out the paper
that they provide and i think they have
code too if i'm not mistaken
and if not it's it should be relatively
easy to
implement this all right that was it
from me bye-bye